after a police shoot our leaves for
robbers dead their widows join forces to
pull off the heist that their husbands
were planning this Steve McQueen
female-centric film has a lot to unpack
from it and throughout this video I'll
be discussing all of the details that
you need to know about widows there will
be heavy spoilers and it may be worth
skipping this video for now if you want
to go into the film with fresh eyes
without the way I'm definition and I
roon it so you don't have to the main
thrust of the story behind widows
revolves around the political war
between the mulligans and Manning's who
are both in competition to become the
18th Ward Alderman of Chicago Manning's
popularity has him as the favorite so in
order to derail his competition's
campaign Mulligan played by Colin
Farrell hires Henry Rawlings played by
Liam Neeson and to rob him
Rawlings manages to get away with two
million dollars of Manning's money but
he and his group of robbers are
seemingly shot and killed in an
explosion by police Manning's
angry that he could lose the battle for
the political position puts pressure on
Rawlings wife Veronica to find a way to
return the money
Veronica discovers her husband's
notebook which details jobs and future
heist and the film goes from there
Veronica assembles a team of widows made
up of their husbands associates and this
includes Alice Linda and Belle who is an
outsider of the group
Manning's uses his closest associates
shut him to stalk and intimidate
Veronica to make sure that she is going
ahead with the plan
the first big twist in the film comes
when we learn that Henry is in fact not
dead and was actually having an affair
with one of his associates wives
Henry was paid by Jack Mulligan to rob
the man in campaign fun and was going to
split the money with him so that Henry
could start a new life Henry currently
has a four month old child with his new
partner and plans to leave the city with
the both of them this is because he and
Veronica had a child together that was
killed by an overly excited policeman
during a traffic stop
clearly the pain was too much for him
and
decided to fake his own death and leave
his life of crime behind and we rigged
the van to explode and alerted the
police so that they would ambush the
group and think that he was killed in
the explosion
Veronica appears to learn this when
going to Henry's girlfriend's house to
recruit her
Veronica discovers Henry's flask and
also their dog is barking at a door but
Veronica refuses to open it to see if
he's there
I believe this is because she was so
invested in the job and making something
of herself that she doesn't want this
reveal so she's away from it as it would
ruin her plans when approaching the job
the group learned that Henry in fact
also has plans to rob the mulligans and
it's a nice twist that hints towards
just how two-faced he really is the
squad carry out the job and in the
process Alice is shot by Jack's father
played by Robert Duvall Linda shoots and
kills him and the group load the money
onto their escape van it's at this point
that she attempt steps forward and robs
them and driving off in the van they
catch up to him and force him off the
road which leads to one of the most
realistic car crash scenes that I've
ever seen in a film the group take the
money
Alice and Linda go to hospital to treat
the former's wound and Belle is dropped
off was Veronica goes back to the
hideout it's at this point that Henry
steps forward and reveals that he is
still alive - Veronica and he tells her
that he needs the money for his new
family he goes to shoot Veronica but
before he can she kills him and stages
the body to look like it was a standoff
that went wrong in the film's epilogue
we learned that Jack Mulligan won the
election due to the city feeling
sympathy over the murder of his father
Linda buys back his store which was
repossessed after her husband's death
Belle leaves to start a new life with
her daughter but not before she leaves
her friend and manager enough money to
that that Archie out to Jack Milligan
Veronica donates the money to the
library which will be dedicated to her
deceased son Marcus in the final scene
of the film she runs into Alice a Adina
who has now been able to leave her life
as an escort behind it due to the money
the two share and exchange and we
finally see Veronica smile which shows
that she's finally let go of all of the
grief that clouded her life she's able
to finally embrace and live a good life
instead of turning a blind eye to the
criminal dealings and predicaments that
her husband put her in it's a really
nice hopeful moment to finish the film
personally I found widows thrilling
touching and empowering this is the
story about taking a loss and turning it
into a positive and whether you are male
or female I think you'll be able to
relate to one of the characters in it
they are all dealing with grief in their
own way and it's a tale as much about
loss as it is king everyone brings their
a game here and delivers the film that
ocean's age should have be this is
definitely worth checking out and makes
another great success for Steve McQueen
so what are your thoughts on widows do
you think it lived up to the hype and
what is your favorite heist movie
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it and
check out my breakdown of the new horror
Overlord which will be linked at the end
of this this is a channel for people who
were mad about movies so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]